[Music]
in doing it wrong news oh yeah
it's the brown wall isn't it put it in
the butt okay
I heard ball cuz he said dishes whatever
you want to call it dick in the brown
balls please submitted by Yamcha intends
them to sum them something Cody it or
does dip some come from then yeah
Mandarin dancing that doesn't even sound
like themself why don't they just call
it being sing yeah big things that
sounds worse my low that he's that
freakin you started writing whatever
they heard cuz you're so weird how they
here they go how does it go and she damn
some got it sounds like Dean sings
without wingdings wings a woman injected
fruit juice directly into her
bloodstream
oh why we try to get vitamins that way
who's the one doing come i was injecting
color that was for his back problem oh
yeah it was objecting his own come you
remembered I forgot
don't you dive on that so this one went
all there behind this is gonna offset
your whole pH and your bloodstream
was it Capri Sun sunny deep sunny big
punch it's already miss Eva gonna get
like vitamins this 51 year old woman you
should know better
no but that's true my aunt is drink piss
what anymore anymore what I bet you your
aunt hates her guts right now she's like
why the [ __ ] do you always tell that
story it was one time I don't do it
anymore smaller opponent
I eat poor Hughie I don't we fell I feel
like meth head Floridians and Chinese
people will get along really well yeah
we wait but yes so she juste 20 types of
fruit but instead of drinking it she
thought it would be a great idea to
inject it directly into her bloodstream
at least you juiced it and shouldn't
just buy like well she's just try to put
a whole apple in her bloodstream and
she's bawling 20 different types of
fruits that's expensive only I know she
had an IV that she that's what
everyone's really impressed about
the supplies and the skills to do an IV
drip which is a doctor of course I hope
she's not a doctor yeah you can't buy
that on Amazon
no it's Alibaba Alibaba makes everything
she started feeling itchy and her
temperature was rising but she did
nothing about it until her husband
noticed that she was feeling really it
was turning like red like he noticed
what there was no fruits in the fridge
oh I was waiting for this one he found
out what she did and so she he took her
to the hospital like this which again is
dudes are crazy as [ __ ] last week she
tried to stick a pair of brass oh yeah
so then they found out that she had a
severe infection damage to her liver
kidney and heart she was done in danger
of dying of multiple organ failure and
sepsis so doctors ended up cleansing her
blood using dialysis why affected
clotting agents and gave her antibiotics
and after five days she was transferred
to a Kiwi unit have been a tomato man I
should have just only did I know what
meter what motivated her to put it in
her bloodstream
she thought that dirt injecting it
directly into her body cuz she's like
well roots are very nutritious like
what's the problem you know I already
know how this happened so sick of
bunches it's like a bunch of women got
together and one of the one of the
friends heard from another friend's
friend who did that and was successful
but then the other ones were like well
I'm too scared I want to try it this
[ __ ] went back home and was like damn
that friends friends friend looks really
good
she knows what she's doing Alma be brave
not like my other bitch-ass friends but
then teen Chinese she did her own
version of what a friend did still yeah
if it was just juicing like that
conversation was like I've been juicing
I've been drinking like smoothies oh
yeah they say if you juice it gets to
your bloodstream quicker yeah they say
that about juicing I don't want to wait
six months I want to be hot now because
growing up with my mom
we never followed the prescription label
what I would get sick I don't get like
amoxicillin or penicillin or whatever
and my mom like like would just start
pouring it should take three of these
and then I'm like wait only says one and
she goes oh no you talking way faster
she always is we never followed the
label on there no just because you [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] ramen there's only a
certain amount that your body can absorb
so everything just gets peed out or
whatever and the night net we never
follow the label God my mom was a nurse
thank God your mom at a normal human
being
I think everyone could say thank God and
your mom it doesn't follow the labels
and she she knows more than a doctor
apparently yeah
I'm surprised she didn't hang you upside
down to bleed you from your ears or
something cleanse the blood yeah people
did that back in the day for them yeah
I'm surprised she didn't get like ten
leeches and put it on your back and [ __ ]
no she uses Western medicine sometimes
but just an Asian way still how do you
even come up with that I don't know what
that there flew in your eye hot oh man
so she lived these are the kidneys good
she's on dialysis yeah well that's
damaged kidneys for a while huh yes yes
to a kidney unit I don't understand why
I like they hate science so much cuz you
don't like being [ __ ] good as grades
and they like math but yeah
why is it when you when it comes to
science and reasoning and logic they
just resist it they're all about
word-of-mouth marketing yeah
that's their shoe room a better man
yeah go better than fact rumor is fact
yeah they don't care that it's in a
science book it's like well what does
this person know this my own opinion
exactly my home will be here did it and
they're fine
because adding dota rules everything we
are they were saying in this article
that some fruits are good for vein
health but that they should never be
injected so I got it right in their help
these veins out just overachievers you
know they're like you know this is
healthy but you know what'll make it
even more healthy straight to the stores
discover the next science fact you know
my parents are more like they're more
what's it called they're very stubborn
and they're also they get to feed it
real quick so for example even try so
for example I'll be like time mom like a
maybe you should eat stuff but that's
more fibrous if you want to have carbs
have like healthier carbs right and I
was like we'll try to teach so much
white rice all the time it's by the way
you didn't gain so much weight because
you eat that with a lot of high fats
right
and she goes what am I supposed to eat
that and I was like vegetable she goes
well I guess I'll starve to death then
you're still eating food what the [ __ ]
you know but she goes no I'll start on
but die that's fine you want me to die
oh my god I love your mom oh oh
I'd like would you take a kid's candy
away yeah yet so much finer she's my
favorite she's just as spicy as she was
when I was younger like she hasn't died
you know my dad has died down a lot it
just doesn't hit you anymore yeah she's
just stuck no she still hits meds at the
block it I'm better blocking though they
just cover up pick it up I can plug it
leg check her stuff it feels good she
said your brother she still hits us all
the time my brother's really funny about
it too cuz he goads her he goes that
doesn't hurt so she'll [ __ ] pinch him
until he bleeds oh my god until he draws
blood he just screams and then he looks
at it maybe I shouldn't have done that
is she stubborn she has to be right ah
so she goes oh it doesn't hurt she'll go
until [ __ ] blood comes out oh god
damn it I'm gonna be your mom so
thinking the same
so stubborn and that's Nikki like and
Steve and I are both stubborn so like if
the kids arguing both of us like you're
like I'll just [ __ ] kill you and make
other ones hard fun it was easy your
body's like oh yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah so
got my uterus
I miss listening to stubborn like old
people but I don't know you you you
don't miss it but then from time to time
you think back and it's [ __ ] so funny
yeah but when it's happening to you your
life it's annoying when it's just
one-on-one it's not fun when I sent a
group at least you can roast them and
like it's funny yeah cuz everyone can
laugh yeah yeah then you like okay at
least rum on the team of not crazies you
know what I realized with Mariel to like
when I'm wrong right I know I'm very
what front leg I it comes out of me I
could see it so you see that my face is
a very honest face right but what'll
happen is like I know I'm supposed to
apologize but I want to give her the
satisfaction so I just don't make eye
contact look at me I'm like you just
tries to make his wrong right like he'll
try to weave it right here just by
debating points instead like he'll
realize he's wrong like mid to be and
then I'll be like well that's what I
meant
back in mono he wanted me when I said
that no I said it like this like if it
was like Oh apples are good for you and
he's like no they're not and then later
he finds out he's wrong I'd be like no I
meant they're not good for you to not
eat like that where I'm like that's not
what you said I don't do that it's so
tiring I know
waste of time he loves debating I'd
rather just do I'd rather just do the
[ __ ] bad German Shepherd thing look
away from her like I'm a vampire she's
sunlight I'm like as you look at me so
grab my faith you do the kids for me
think
I can't do it cuz I can't do it because
I'm so embarrassed of myself and I'm
like yeah but what's hella wrong like
it's what I'm so [ __ ] clearly wrong I
have nothing to say so I just [ __ ]
avoid eye-contact hate that [ __ ] about
myself I just run my mouth till I lose
energy and then I'm done
that's why Asian dudes calm down after a
while they're just balls of rage and
then they like when they're old they're
like ah suck it to some tires no point
yeah just don't make eye contact it was
the best now my whole thing is like I
want to know what's really right every
time you have a disagreement right mhm
so there's your truth my truth in actual
truth I want to skip both of that past
the ego figure out what the actual truth
is because there's progress there but
what's preventing me is my impulse at
the moment yeah cuz my impulse is a
caveman
but inside deep inside there's actually
a really smart guy
yeah and the really smart guy never
comes out he's a [ __ ] nerd he gets
his ass kicked right Marion has to get
tired and then I get to I get to listen
I bet the therapist could shut the
Barbarian up not if I shut the therapist
though
[Music]